I apologize in advance but this is going
to be like a little bit of a rant
segment I'm really sick of a particular
type of message that I received a few of
recently about Elon Musk and Tesla and
it's the you must be ignoring this
particular story because of some
personal bias David and you're a bad
person here's one example I received
like a half a dozen of these in the last
few weeks and the gist is the same for
all of them this is just one example so
someone who on Reddit goes by the name
sinker
posts guys David and Elon what's up with
David totally avoiding the Elon news
he's barely touched on it I know he
drives a Tesla but that can't be why
he's dodging this Insight sorry if it's
been asked so two components okay the
first component is I've been ignoring
the story of Elon Musk buying Twitter
and genuinely behaving like a [ __ ] and
part two is that it's because I drive a
Tesla or I'm an investor in Tesla so
let's take the questions in two parts
first have I been ignoring it no I have
not in November alone we have seven
YouTube videos either directly or
indirectly about Elon Musk and Twitter
one of those is Tucker talking about an
Elon Musk conspiracy theory this
includes a story yesterday on Elon Musk
unbanning Trump from Twitter we've
covered it on the bonus show endless
additional times since the beginning of
Elon Musk looking at buying Twitter
dozens and dozens of Stories the stories
don't do super well
I consider that a signal that my
audience isn't that interested in it but
there has been plenty of coverage that's
number one secondly and this is really
the part that I want to address is the
idea that I'm not covering it or I am
covering it in a particular way because
I drive a Tesla or I'm a Tesla investor
we saw another version of this with
stuff with the israeli-palestinian
conflict I'm not covering it because I'm
Jewish and then it's well I covered it
in a certain way because I'm Jewish and
then I'm covering it a lot because I'm
Jewish okay
first of all
this entire Tesla thing is silly but
more importantly
I'm no huge Tesla fan and in fact I
would gladly stop being a Tesla driver
if I could get out of my Tesla lease
without it costing me money so let me
give you the full story and maybe we can
put this to bed I bought Tesla stock in
2015.
that's almost eight years ago as of last
week I've now sold the vast majority of
the stock
I plan to sell all of it I want to wait
until January 1st to sell what's left
because I want to spread out the capital
gains that I'm going to owe and not owe
a whole bunch of taxes all at once now
if by the way the stock is tanking if it
keeps losing value between now and when
I sell in early January I might not even
owe taxes because I'll have you know my
gains will have evaporated that's number
one I bought the stock not because of
being some Elon Musk Fanboy but because
I believed that Tesla as a first mover
into longer range electric vehicles was
going to do well as a company the stock
did do well but I also knew including
from driving the car myself Tesla's big
Advantage is being the first mover on
the charging network and on the on the
Range the build quality of Tesla
vehicles isn't that great it's not that
great and I can tell you as someone who
has a Tesla right now
I've driven in uh BMW electric vehicles
Audi Mercedes Porsche they are way
better cars than Tesla I've ridden in a
friend's Hyundai ioniq 5. uh okay it's a
little bit of a lower priced car but
it's still these companies have been
building cars for in some cases a
hundred years they are way better built
vehicles I believe that the first mover
Advantage for Tesla is clearly
diminishing and as that happens it's
less of an interesting company so I'm
going to be getting out great that Tesla
was a first mover and push things
forward
I think it's prospects in the future are
not nearly as bright now in terms of my
lease and being a Tesla driver I would
bail on it today but I would have to pay
a lease early termination fee it's like
a bunch of payments doesn't matter it
would be forty five hundred dollars if I
want to turn in my lease today I can do
it but it's 4 500 wasting forty five
hundred dollars because I think Elon
Musk is clearly now a knucklehead
doesn't seem super logical if you people
who are angry with me about the car want
to pay for the early termination fee I
will gladly turn in the car
turn in the keys there are no keys and
film myself doing it okay and then we'll
turn it into content and I'll get a
different card the only reason I still
drive a Tesla today is I have a lease
and unless I want to pay I have to keep
the car to the end of the lease lastly
Elon Musk
um I believe Elon Musk has fallen into
the reactionary libertarian black hole I
think it's a very dumb black hole that
many have fallen into I think his
purchase of Twitter is bad for social
media and it's bad for Twitter I also
recognize he's had successful businesses
and people in the past who have bet
against his businesses came out on the
wrong sides of many of those bets I
don't find him super interesting as an
individual that's the full story there's
no hidden agenda I'm not avoiding
talking about Twitter or Elon Musk or
Tesla there's no secret Tesla driver
silence or Allegiance or any of it so
please folks let's drop it
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below